in Dark Souls 1 the age of ancients was
surpassed and the age of fire began in
Dark Souls 2 the world is caught between
light and dark unable to move on and in
Dark Souls 3 I think will break the
cycle and see what lies beyond light and
dark what's up guys let's talk about
some law specifically the clues we've
seen in Dark Souls 3 so far and what
they could indicate about the direction
of the story let's get into it so the
first thing we need to address is the
timeline where are we within it and
right from the very beginning we see
things that are baffling from a timeline
perspective even if you're somewhat
familiar with the law these next few
things should raise questions with you
there are ancient dragons there's an
analogous this building that looks like
an Orlando and it also looks like the
dragon shrine the castle is full of
hollows the player character doesn't
Hollow and the Lords of cinder are
coming back to life so yeah there's a
lot of stuff to digest here but we can
break it down before we do that though I
think it's important that we're all on
the same page you can skip this if you
like Dark Souls 1 showed us the gray age
of ancients and then the progression to
an age of fire that was destined to fade
until only dark remained but win
sacrificed himself to link fire
preventing his age of fire from ending
Dark Souls 2 taught us that this was the
first sin causing countless kingdoms to
rise and fall since then
all following this template that Gwyn
set in the first cycle every time the
flame is about to fade someone fights
their way to the kiln of the first flame
and sacrifices themselves before it can
fade entirely they do this for the good
of the world supposedly at the end of
Dark Souls 2
we were just another one of these fated
beings who made it to the kiln we can
choose to link fire here and continue
the order of the world but we also
learned that there are some undead
powerful enough to reject light and dark
entirely to walk away from both and to
try and find and
other paths and if none of that made
sense then you should probably watch
this video where I go into more detail
and finally we arrived at Dark Souls 3
with all these interesting lower
implications hidden within the network
test first up let's talk about the
everlasting stone Dragons that appear
one is living two are dead the one that
lives can be killed which I find a
little bit strange and the other
deceased dragons are being worshipped
hollows pray to them as their scales
flake away in the wind and there's even
this area where a bunch of chairs are
all arranged to face the dragon these
dragons seem out of place at first
glance but really the idea that the
ancient dragons could be coming back as
an influence in the world isn't so
strange there have always been secret
dragon covenants after all amongst all
these throwbacks to the age of ancients
is this castle filled to the brim with
hollowed soldiers and lights so clearly
the curse has already decimated
civilization the curse is at that point
just like in previous games but most
curiously you're not one of these undead
the player character who has always
famously been teetering between humanity
and hollowing now seems completely
bereft of a hollow state you don't
hollow in Dark Souls 3 from what we've
seen so far
instead you can consume an ember to go
into what's called lord of cinder form
where your maximum health is boosted
just like consuming a humanity would do
in Dark Souls 1 or 2 and we aren't the
only Lord of cinder at the end of the
demo we find this creature the dancer of
the frigid Valley she's called when
defeated your screen reads air of fire
destroyed that's interesting in previous
Souls games it's always been you
defeated or victory achieved air of fire
destroyed has a much different tone to
it it actually reminds me of blood-borne
where it says prey slaughtered or more
specifically nightmare slain when you
kill a creature or a boss that has a
certain significance to your journey
and the word air is significant to Dark
Souls it's been used before and it was
actually a word that was added to
descriptions in Dark Souls 2 scholar of
the first sin the soul of nashandra
description from Dark Souls 2 reads one
day the flames will fade and only
darkness will remain unless of course an
air arrives
therefore these beings are logically
either beings that inherited the fire at
the end of a cycle or beings that are
meant to inherit it these are creatures
that inherited the fire much in the way
that Gwyn did and it's clear that our
character is hunting them down that's
really interesting that's different from
previous souls games that's good I
remember in an interview with Miyazaki
people questioned him about the Lord of
cinder title a lot of people asked do
you mean Gwyn and he cryptically implied
that we'll be seeing more than just Gwyn
he says if Dark Souls 1 was a story of
killing a god Dark Souls 3 is a story
about killing Lords these heirs of fire
and I assume synonymously lords of
cinder are rising again
speaking of resurrection in the trailer
our Bell Tolls and another Lord of
cinder rises and this one is clearly a
giant from Dark Souls 2 I'm going on a
bit of a tangent here but this implies
that not just humans can link the fire
this role of inheriting the fire could
have fallen to the giants as well the
beginning of a cycle might just be a
chance for a new race to take control
and this creature could have been a part
of them it looks so different to the
dance of the humans and Gwyn and it
looks very similar to the giant Lord
which was also the only giant and
ourselves to that wielded a sword so
there's a lot of connections there if
you consume an ember you go into Lord of
cinder form which well implies that you
might be an air of fire too and as one
final note it's off on a bit of a
tangent again but we've heard a lot
about the rumored bonfire sacrifice
mechanic whereby you can sacrifice what
looks like a corpse and create a bonfire
and this reminds me a lot of what Gwyn
did when he linked the fire you know he
sacrificed himself to create more
so the bonfire sacrifice mechanic might
be related to that but back to the
original question which was what part of
the timeline are we in all of this
indicates that it's a sequel to previous
games and to me it looks like we're at
an extreme end of the cycle something
fairly significant is happening for
heirs of fire to rise again for the
Dragons to return and for a few
screenshots to show the abyss trying to
take over as well it's almost like
everything is fighting for control so is
this the very beginning of a cycle or is
at the very end in our interview with
Miyazaki he mentioned that the game
takes place in a post-apocalyptic world
and that will see the faded elegant
beauty of past civilizations
I thought his choice of words was
interesting an apocalypse
is an event of mass destruction and the
most apocalyptic event I can think of is
the fire being linked as characters like
the Emerald Herald and Strayed say that
Souls will flourish anew and that a new
Kingdom is going to be born and it's
going to sport a new face if this is a
world immediately post the fire being
linked in a post-apocalyptic world then
it could explain why a lot of the world
seems covered in ash as well but I do
think there's more evidence to the
contrary I don't think this looks like a
world where the flame is all-powerful so
I don't think it's a world immediately
after the fire has been linked it's
clearly a world where only embers remain
and
the Lord's have no Thrones the word
throne has a lot of significance if
you've played Dark Souls 2 in Dark Souls
2 the throne of want at the end was
clearly in the shape of a kiln and was
meant to represent that he who sat upon
it had the power to reshape the world
and could sacrifice themselves to
linking the fire if the Lords of cinder
presumably have no Thrones then it
follows that they're struggling to link
the fire at the end of this cycle and
this lines up with a few things the
world of Dark Souls 3 looks tired and
gray hollows pray to the trees and the
Dragons and some hollows even appear to
have become trees I have this theory
bouncing around in my head that these
hollows are just wishing for a return to
a gray age where nothing lived and
nothing died the world just looks so
much like it wants release but this is
just speculation there's also the
concept of pilgrimage which is a
familiar one in dark souls pilgrimage in
these games has always been a holy
journey of fateful significance in Dark
Souls 1 undead were funneled towards
Lordran following the rumor of freedom
from the curse which when you think
about it was a convenient excuse for
going on pilgrimage since manipulative
serpents like calf and frampt wanted
undead to go on pilgrimage so they could
push them towards Gwyn so if undead are
coming to this land in pilgrimage maybe
it's in that same desperate attempt to
link the fire once more and so I do
think it's most logical that there's
this big push to link the fire and you
know what's interesting about that
what's really cool is that the idea that
the Lords have no Thrones probably isn't
helped by the fact that we're actually
hunting down these heirs of fire which
leads us to our player character what
are our motivations in this game as
mentioned before the player character
doesn't hollow in the network test
additionally the humanity item appears
to have been replaced by these embers
which are shaped suspiciously like
Humanity sprites except they're infused
with fire
and that's not incredibly strange when
you think about it fire and dark have
always been intertwined scholar of the
first sin even changed the bow of want
description to clarify that light and
dark are two sides of the same coin it
also changed the chime of want
description to clarify that fragments of
dark seek monarchs of light to attach
themselves to
and we always offered humanity to a
bonfire to become human in Dark Souls 1
so it's not so strange that these two
themes fire in dark are inseparable here
just like the embers one of the things
I'm fascinated by most though is the
fact that we don't hollow particularly
because hollowing was one of those
things that we conquered in Dark Souls 2
by uniting the three crowns of Lords
long past
you no longer hollow upon death now this
isn't to say that our Dark Souls 2
character cured the curse rather it
means that somehow possessing these
crowns overcomes that force that makes
you Hollow and it's worth talking about
those crowns that stop our character
from hollowing in Dark Souls 2 not just
because a character in Dark Souls 3
doesn't seem to Hollow but also because
there's this crown shown in the
cinematic trailer and if you look really
closely you'll even see the dark signs
swirling within this crown and the dark
sign is the sign of the undead that
marks them as cursed and marks them as
beings doomed to Hollow it makes me
wonder if maybe this represents how the
crown contains the curse of the undead
and it makes me wonder who's picking up
this crown who's putting it on and
lastly it makes me wonder if this crown
has the power of the Crown's from Dark
Souls 2 where lack of hollowing could
make us unlike any undead that's come
before us and this brings me to my
conclusion the truth is obviously I
don't know what's going to happen at the
end of Dark Souls 3 even with these
clues but I'm going to make an estimated
guess just like I hope many of you guys
do in the comments that you write and my
theories as always aren't necessarily
more correct than anyone else's maybe
someone will contrary
maeín come up with something even better
that would be awesome I think that in
Dark Souls 1 Gwyn committed the first
sin which was linking the fire what he
linked the fire to is the big question
and the answer I think that fits most is
that he linked it to humanity it
explains why Humanity is linked to the
fate of the flame where they weren't
supposed to be before aldia calls man's
life after this point a lie and
construction and a facade and yet a
world full of warmth and resplendence
humanity literally starts to feed the
bonfires with humanity they're bound to
them and they're unable to die as a
result the soul of nashandra tells us
that one day the flames will fade and
that only dark will remain unless of
course an air arrives and an air always
does arrive even in the midst of dark
like we see in Dark Souls 2 are
determined and potentially manipulated
Undead always finds his way to the kiln
it's the only way mankind can be
released from the curse according to
characters like Qarth and the Emerald
Herald these are characters that guide
you and motivate you and fill you with
determination you need to acquire Souls
and link the fire and supposedly save
the world you're this undying force
remember as long as you have the
determination not to go hollow the
undead reaches the throne the flame is
bolstered Souls flourish in you and
everything plays out again mind you
everyone talks about cycles a lot as if
they're unavoidable as if the age of
dark can never come to pass because the
world is stuck in a cycle but we don't
know this for certain the narrator in
Dark Souls one's prologue says one day
the flame will fade and only dark will
remain and she makes it sound like an
inevitability if we can take any
character at their word it's probably
the all-knowing narrator right
even if countless kingdoms have risen
and fallen even if the flame has been
linked hundreds of times what if during
one age no air of fire answers the call
what if a character like nashandra
actually did a half competent job of
keeping undead out of the kiln it's
possible an age of dark could still come
it's possible a true age of dark hasn't
been seen yet don't rule that
possibility out aldea tried to find
another way out of the cycle he tried to
surpass it
to go beyond light and dark since both
of them are linked he experimented on
Giants he created a dragon that gave
birth to the herald but even the herald
herself says that all attempts to
overcome the curse failed at the end
aldea appears disfigured by his
experiments he's hopeless and he watches
as we walk away from the throne towards
this uncertain future beyond the scope
of light beyond the reach of dark
what could possibly await us and yet we
seek it insatiably QED Dark Souls 3 I
get the impression that the world is
tired unable to move on perhaps the fire
hasn't been linked in a very long time
since apparently only embers remain and
I wonder if it's like this because of
our player character if we're hunting
down there's a fire perhaps we're trying
to let the world finally progress into
an age of dark that would line up with
the embrace the darkness tagline the
Dark Souls 3 has on the website maybe
the world will finally move on and Lords
of cinder will come back in a desperate
attempt to stop that from happening or
maybe we are opposed to darkness as well
after all we are infused with embers we
rely upon and covet the flame because of
what Gwyn did to us this is what we are
now or a fusion of dark and fire and
fire is a part of us perhaps we're still
seeking that unknown goal of Dark Souls
to his final ending where we want to
discover what lies beyond light what
lies beyond dark and we need to take a
leap of faith and no air of fire and no
spawn of Darkness should stand no way